I am Eric Smith with assured flow
solutions from Houston Texas today I'll
be talking about all the
interoperability of the Wolfram language
with cloud services platforms as a
service and how we are love achievement
to build a lab information management
system for surance lab I'm Eric Smith I
work at a shirt flow solutions down in
Houston and this is my 20th year using
Mathematica and the Wolfram language the
first 10 years I thought all that
Mathematica was good for was symbolic
solutions and manipulation of equations
in fact in grad school I would I do all
my symbolic work in Mathematica and then
convert it to MATLAB code and do the
numerix there it wasn't until years 11
through 17 that I realized it was much
more capable including the numerical
bits and I would use file string
manipulation every day and then netlink
just became very powerful for what I did
at work in the last few years I've
really delved into UI development
building front ends utilities for the
company but every step along the way I
pretty much underestimated what the
Wolfram language could do and it
happened again this year when I was
building the laboratory information
management system or limbs and so that's
what I'll be talking about today and
what I'll be going through is a brief
introduction of what a flow assurance
lab is but really the main topic is
building a data management platform so
I'll talk about what the issue was what
commercial options are available and how
this fits into our software package
Aleks that we built in-house that's all
built on Wolfram language and then we'll
go through some of the details of the
Wolfram language laboratory information
management system that I'm building what
the database is storage and how that
works into our lab utilities and then
finally I have some ideas of how the
Wolfram framework including the cloud
and desktop can fit into the oil and gas
industry
perhaps a little bit better so flow
assurance really basic explanation would
be once you put a well in the ground
what you pull out can be kind of nasty
stuff a lot about things can happen
between the well and the platform some
of those things are hydrates which are
big ice like structures made from
methane and water here we have picture
of a couple waxes you can see this one
when you turn the bottle over fell to
the bottom this one did it so that's
kind of hard to flow through a pipeline
emulsions if you have some water and
your that creates an emulsion with your
oil it turns into this nasty
peanutbutter chocolaty looking stuff
that's also very difficult to flow other
things we look at scale asphaltenes
chemical stability material stability
corrosion and general fluid
characterization so problem with our
data management system for the past four
years we've been running these
experiments and then throwing the
results and onto the network drives I
think everyone would understand the
problem there you are very reliance on
your folder structure it's not very
searchable it's not even index than
Windows I can't query data it's
definitely not computation computable
data and there was kind of an ink
incongruity with with our lab and our
data so we have this very modern
state-of-the-art lab it's very clean
it's actually a really nice place to
work but if you were to illustrate what
our data looked like it's it's more like
this
the information is in there but you know
good luck finding it and so we needed to
do more what are what are some of our
goals well we need our data to be
computable we'd like to be able to query
by what we've done for certain clients
or what we've done on a certain test or
by a property of a fluid we want to be
able to perform data analytics on past
results and also to provide insight
based off of previous experiments and
previous engineering work so we're
primarily an engineering firm and we
have a lab to kind of support the
engineering work and so we we do these
measurements put that right into our
simulations and would be good to to get
a new sample say oh this looks a lot
like when we did two years ago and here
were the results of our flow assurance
engineering and of course we would like
to streamline the lab process in general
when we get the sample in it should be
logged all that logging information
should be used when we go and run the
tests and make the reports and so there
are a bunch of commercially available
limbs on the market but my instinct is
to just go open a notebook and try to
start doing seen what I can do from
scratch and that's when I have to check
what I'm calling my Wolfram hubris and
by that it's the belief you're more
capable of creating a better product
from scratch than those delivered by
long-standing successful companies
because you have the power of Wolfram
technologies I don't know who else has
felt this way but I know Wolfram
research does because they're building
their own ERP and I kept telling myself
that when I was looking at limbs
solutions well I mean they're making
their own ERP and ERPs are pretty
terrible so maybe there's something here
the difference is I'm not Wolfram
research I'm a Guyot assured flow
solutions so we did look at the
commercial solutions and they're more
than 200 products on the market and the
thing is is they're ideally suited for
repetitive tasks so if you have 200
tests that you have to get through your
lab and five different types of
experiments that's ideal for limbs and
you just spit out the numbers and give
it back well we do is we have about 20
tests per week and on 70 different
experiments and that's a lot harder to
configure and additionally we we don't
just take the output from the machines
and hand it to so the clients we do
engineering work on that we do
additional calculations we've been using
the Wolfram language to support our lab
for years
and and those programs didn't convert
over into a commercial limb system so we
we built our own in Alex and Alex was
kind of the the basis that we're going
to well it had all of our lab
calculations in it and we had all of our
engineering calculations in it so if I
get out of full screen here and open
Alex Andrew you'll person it on this a
couple years ago and the reason why Alex
exists is that engineering firms tend to
create piles of Excel spreadsheets and
utilities in network drives with
different versioning you know version
one version to version April 2018 and
it's impossible to know what you what
you're using what you should be using
and so our founder and CEO kind of had
the foresight to say hey we need to put
all this information in one place and it
needs to be version controlled everybody
needs to be using the same utilities so
no mistakes are made so we have all
types of flow assurance calculations in
here and so this is a natural place to
build our limbs there we go alex is what
word form no web form no this is
actually a CDF for this is a Wolfram
base yes yeah we deployed this with a
Enterprise CDF yeah let me just
there this
yeah so really the story here is about
interoperability when I said I
underestimated the Wolfram language it
was in its ability to talk to all these
platforms as a service so to build the
Lim's we using cloud storage AWS s3 and
database connectivity were using MongoDB
and then when we're ready to report out
we were using net link creating common
objects to talk to Excel sending values
over to Excel but we're moving away from
that and using report templates in the
Wolfram language and then miscellaneous
kind of pseudo interoperability working
with files and exporting PDFs and
potentially deploying to the cloud so a
few years ago I saw the presentation and
I think at WTC of [ __ ] link and looks
pretty full-featured you can see there's
quite a few functions associated with it
and so we got started with [ __ ] Atlas
and just to see what the Wolfram
language could do with MongoDB and we
created four collections to keep track
of our clients or projects our samples
and tests and we built some convenience
functions in here so if we want to find
a sample with the sample ID right it
will return the object we can do more
advanced queries we're going to look for
tests of this type done between these
days and we're going to return that
object and get the samples out of that
object and return the samples from the
sample sample collection and so fairly
advanced queries can be built pretty
easily and there were a lot of surprises
again I wasn't expecting all this to
just be ready out of the box I thought
it was no it's it's gone [ __ ] Atlas
required a certificate authority turns
out that's hidden in your Mathematica
files hopefully this is here where did
they all go
okay well some worth writing all of it
here oh thank you
perfect yeah I haven't seen that I guess
haven't been checking this in
presentation mode yeah so anyway there's
a mungus [ __ ] default certificate
authority file I don't know if this has
happened to you when you're googling a
solution you find some syntax that
doesn't look like Wolfram language code
and it's impossible if I find Wolfram
language code what was really nice as I
found out that Jason is really
interchangeable with Wolfram language
expressions so if you use import string
and you copy
you know this text from the Help section
of MongoDB you can turn it directly into
a Wolfram language expression and
similarly when you're talking from
Wolfram language back to MongoDB you can
write your Association or whatever your
Wolfram expression and export the string
as raw JSON and you get a JSON string I
didn't know how common that knowledge
was but I found it very useful and if
there's something that's not in [ __ ]
link you can always use external
evaluate and python and that's how we
actually got started and it's it's
really easy to use PI [ __ ] straight
from the notebook which is calling
Python some of the things to realize is
that there are constantly updates to
[ __ ] link that's good to to see that
Steven mentioned that last night that
there even more coming in 12.1 1 in the
ones that I found in from 11.3 212 is
that you could only send dates of
strings previously and now it supports
data objects so now you know you can
find all the samples entered in our
database for the past 15 days whatever
whatever operation you want to use dates
for
now cloud storage was tricky found out
that there's this undocumented library
called AWS link and we didn't know how
we were going to deploy this if we're
going to deploy this in the cloud
through a PC or through a PC or through
Enterprise CDF and the problem why is is
I had just switched to the pre-release
of twelve point oh and found out that aw
AWS link no longer contained the s3
functions they moved to another
undocumented library external storage
which Stephen said last night is now
going to be documented in 12.1 so there
was this what are we going to do in the
meantime type of question and I figured
undocumented libraries wouldn't be
supported in the cloud so I looked at
creating REST API with AWS and this is
where things got really messy because
AWS doesn't recommend that you use these
they say you should use their their Java
API if possible but J link is also not
enabled and Wolfram cloud so I used
their c-sharp example code and thought
for sure I was going to get stuck that
there would be no equivalents in the
Wolfram language because you had to take
this different information about your
content the content type Amazon hash
information whatever it was and then you
have to do hashes of hashes bashes in
this HMAC base64 encryption method which
luckily somebody on Stack Exchange had
had helped me less so anyway you you
create this very complex header with all
these different functions that I had
pretty much never touched in my life and
the Wolfram language but when I needed
them they were there and and in the end
I was able to use the REST API eyes to
push information to the cloud and pull
it from s3 as well for the report
templates like I mentioned we were using
Excel and creating calm objects and
doing sudo VBA code and the Wolfram
language which required a lot of manual
coding to send each value to the correct
cell the creation of the of the
spreadsheets were slow and the most
inferior
is that once you created this
spreadsheet it depended if you depended
on if you opened it and Excel 365 or
2016 or if it was 32-bit 64-bit Windows
Mac every time we opened it it wasn't
lined up correctly graphs or plots would
go over the margin and of course there
were no repeating blocks like we have in
the Wolfram language templates so now we
write some templates that's you know we
format the document we create headers
footers include our logo in there
we have our slots for the information
we're passing from the kernel over into
this new notebook and we even use
repeating blocks so that in the end this
is all made of data so nothing secret
here we have a very nicely formatted PDF
that does our linear and exponential
fitting and looks very similar to the
documents that we were making by hand
the difference is this takes two minutes
to make this other ones you know took an
hour so some of the pros and cons I
enjoy staying in the Wolfram language
not converting from VBA to Wolfram
language the repeating blocks is really
helpful and being able to script the
documentation formatting the negatives
I saw John Folse has talked this morning
about DPI's and how that gets very
confusing and in fact it does appear to
be a bug that when you set your M's or
your printer points to try to get get at
the right size and your template or your
PDF it doesn't go exactly what you where
you want it to go in the right size and
you actually have to do a bit of guess
and check formatting
so I brought up Alex but I wanted to
show the utilities that we have so we
have kind of the starting points is our
lab entry utility where we can update
information about our clients or
projects or samples associate samples
with projects and clients with projects
etc and then once all that information
is entered we can go to one of our lab
utilities and this will instead of going
through your folder structure and
hunting down the data that you took you
can just see that it's filtered only the
projects that were run for this
experiment and then of course only the
samples that were in that project so a
lot less hunting a lot better access to
your data then you up some upload some
of your information to the cloud into
the database and all the information
that you've ever submitted to the
database since s3 the sitting here for
you to analyze you can you know put your
inputs in here and then you generate
your report so basically to illustrate
what we're doing is this was the input
boxes required before for our DSC tests
but all this information we should have
already entered somewhere and now it's
in the database so all we do is select
your project your sample the client
information the information about the
sample all that is pulled in so now all
you have to do is focus on inputting the
information from the test so some
thoughts on the Wolfram cloud I use the
interoperability as a Wolfram language a
lot and unfortunately that's where the
Wolfram cloud doesn't really supports
the fundamental features of the Wolfram
language so you know netlink j-link
can't be used for security reasons and I
understand [ __ ] link is built on J link
and that's not accessible
undocumented libraries like AWS an
external sort of storage wouldn't be
supported and not necessarily forelimbs
but we have a need to use system modeler
in the in the cloud and that's not yet
supported and so that's just as a
company we kind of wait until those
things are adopted until we can really
kind of embrace Wolfram cloud we use it
for other things but I really we could
we could use a lot more if it we had a
way of using the interoperability in the
language the interest of time I'm gonna
skip that and finish with some of the
conclusions that assured flow solutions
we've built a data management platform
the server lab the data management
platform is built on platform
as-a-service solutions and can be
customized for other companies and
applications we're streamlining the lab
experiments from the proposal process to
the report generation using the Wolfram
language and the interoperability and
the Wolfram language is powerful and
more complete than I imagined most
people think it is it's a testament to
Wolfram's vision of maintaining a
development platform that doesn't
require a library hunting and I put this
quote in here from John McLean's blog
post figuring out how other people want
to use tools and creating workflows that
are broadly useful is one of those
longtail development problems that open
source typically leaves to the user to
solve it was really nice to be able to
open up a notebook and have everything
that I needed so that's take any
questions thank you
you